OOF!
Don't let him close his fist.
*wraps*
Aargh!
Magic!
More magic!
*grunt*
Magic with a kick!
Magic with a--
*grunt*
Insect!
*throws*
*OUCHIE*
*tears*
*Pew pew*
*Explosions*
*Pew pew pew*
*More explosions*
Yaaaaaah!
YEEET!!
OOF!
*explosions*
*grunting*
*Pull*
*OUCH*
*BOOM*
*Punch*
I'm sorry, Earth is closed today!
you better pack it up, and get out of here.
Stone keeper...
??
Does this chattering animal speak for you?
Certainly not, I speak for myself.
You're trespassing in this city and on this planet.
He means get lost Squidward!
He exhausts me...
*alien noises*
Bring me the stone
*more alien noises*
Banner, you wanna piece?
No, not really but, when do I ever get what I want?
That's right.
KHUUUH
Been a while
It's gonna be good to have you, buddy.
m'kay, shhh
Let me just..
I need to concentrate here for a second...
'cmon!
'cmon, man!
RAH! *slam*
Where's your guy?
*sigh*
I dunno, we've sort of been having a thing.
There's no time for a thing,
I kno-
That's a thing right there, let's go!
*alien noise*
*grunts as hard as he can*
........
Dude, you're embarrassing me in front of the wizard..
I'm sorry! I-I-I can't or he won't I like, I, I don't-
It's okay, hey, stand down,
Keep an eye on him? Thank you.
Are you yawning?!
*yawns*
In the middle of this? While I'm breakin' it down?
huh?
Did you hear what I said?
I stopped listening after you said "We need a plan."
Okay, Mr. Clean is on his own page.
See, not winging it isn't really what they.. do.
Uh, what exactly is it that they do?
Kick names, take ass.
Yeah, that's right.
*loses all hope for the universe*
Alright, just get over here, please.
Mr. Lord, can you get your folks to circle up-
"Mister Lord"... Star Lord, is fine.
We've gotta coalesce,
'cause if all we come out with is a plucky attitude-
Dude...
don't call us plucky..
We don't know what it means.
Alright, we're optimistic, yes.
I like you're plan, except, it sucks,
So let me do the plan, and that way, It might be really good.
*BOOM*
I'm gonna ask one time...
Who are you?!
We're the Avengers, man..
*SPOILERS*
*Disappears*
Thanos...
If he gets all the Infinity Stones,
He'll wipe out half the universe.
Everything you know, everything you love, it will all be gone.
Just like that...
Well, he's never fought me!
Yeah, he has.
He's never fought me twice!
*grunting*
*OOF!*
And I'm getting a new hammer!
It better be some hammer.
*Bifrost Zappy Sound*
*Wakanda battle cry!*
He's comin' to us, I say we take the fight to him!
*LIGHTING*
*Tear*
*Woosh*
*Pew*
AAAAHAAH! You guys are screwed now!
Yes!
*Epic running scene*
*A new movie by Michael Bay*
*Woosh*
*Punch*
Graarr!
Oh, by the way this is a friend of mine,  tree.
I am Groot!
I am Steve Rodgers.
*Punch punch punch*
Bingo!
Alright!
*Snores*
*Stabs*
*Pew*
YYYYYYYYYEEEETTTTTTTTT!!!!!!
*Kick*
Together,
We can stop Thanos.
*Throws meteors*
DUUUUUUU!
DUUUUUUU!DUUUU!
DUUUUUUU!DUUUU!DUU!
DUUUUUUU!DUUUU!DUU!DUU!
DUUUUUUU!DUUUU!DUU!DUU!DUUUUU!
DUUUUUUU!DUUUU!DUU!DUU!DUUUUU!DUUUU!
DUUUUUUU!DUUUU!DUU!DUU!DUUUUU!DUUUU!DUUUUUUUUUUUU!
*RIP Title*
*skkrrt*
Where's your guy?
*alien noises*
ngggghhhhhh!!
Dude, you're embarrassing me in front of the wizard...
I'm sorry!
Don't embarrass people in front of wizards